first of all just because somebody is of
a particular group does not mean they're
right Piers Morgan gets brought up a few
times throughout the book is it
coincidental or does he just happen to
embroil himself in these situations a
lot the reference is Tim and not that
obliging and he's definitely one of
those characters who throws himself into
things in his case we're just you know
Glee the moment when your integrated
really into a society is not when you
get anything special or anything ex
renting Walker though when you're really
integrated is when you rise you just
have to put up at the same if the rest
of us have to put up with we're living
at a stage where we might be among the
first people in human history to have
absolutely no explanation for what we're
doing here I'm now gonna be accused of
biphobia all my other have many many
crimes but anyhow the ridiculous person
who complains on the BBC that they are
often ridiculed in public and that's not
nice but I point out if you're
ridiculous you will be ridiculed I'm
joined by Douglas Murray author of the
madness of crowds and best-selling
author of the strange death of Europe
Douglas welcome the show it's really
great pleasure to join you so far we've
had a couple of a couple of technical
issues but got through them fine and now
we get on at the real issues first
things first
manners have crowd you new book four
chapters women gay race and trans each
one of those is a nuclear warhead
beneath my foot how how are we going to
be able to navigate this conversation
and how also did you navigate this
without game blown up well I I don't
know I have survived so far the books
behaving a fortnight my view is is that
we've become in our societies really bad
at having conversations we've become
very bad at thinking because we can't
think out loud or at least the price of
thinking out loud has become potential
total career and life destruction so
when people wonder why people don't do
it it's it's not hard
find the frites and I think that for
some some reason in recent years I
noticed that these four issues in
particular there are others but these
four issues in particular were the ones
which people just kept on you know the
moment they knit the tripwire
they were just detonated and I just
found that really interesting also
because I think all four issues are
unbelievably interesting and and
actually significant I mean have
significant effects on people's lives
and on our society so my view is that
we've got this strange position in our
societies at the moment we're the only
people who can sort of speak or think
out loud at people who don't have any
hierarchy above them that's the
vulnerable to crowd stampedes and mobs
and so on so those of us who can think
aloud whether we're right or wrong I
don't know but sort of have a
disproportionate duty to talk and think
and right and so I decided just to take
each of the absolute nuclear bomb issues
head-on and just go jumping on in you
certainly did whether any I was going to
ask you this at the end but I'm you know
ask it now and whether any chapters that
you could have considered adding that
you did that's a very good question
there there were two that I could have
done that I didn't okay one one was
Green okay which I have been becoming
more and more interested in and I think
there's whatever people's views about
the the nature of climate change and the
best way to deal with it and so on is
it's clear there is at this point an
element of crowd mentality that's
kicking in and I suppose the other one
that was that where I could have done I
thought about doing but decide to put
off to another day was mental health
because I think that mental health in
general is a fascinating fascinating
issue it's come very fast into the
mainstream and I think we no good in all
sorts of ways but there are lots of
issues around mental health that I'm
very skeptical about not
you know need to get into all of them
but III don't entirely share a lot of
the presumptions of the age and I think
that it basically it has some of the
same aptitudes of the things I'm
discussing here is that you get on to
the thing and you don't know where to
correct or it becomes almost impossible
to say stop at any point
and I tell you I mean with the mental
health one just not bang on but one the
ones I noticed a few years ago was that
there were certain mental illnesses that
people clearly wanted to have and once
they did it well okay so you just
invited me to jump in paid highly few
atomic bomb but I were here we go
let's desert I noticed for instance
speaking to dr. friends and everyone
that bipolar this isn't to say that
there aren't people who are bipolar but
that it was a good thing some people
thought to have diagnosed similar to OCD
right and and what's striking to me is
that there are mental health afflictions
that are just definitely not the ones
that people want and they are under
diagnosed by comparison so schizophrenia
but nobody thinks it's cool to be
schizophrenic and right whereas on a
date somebody's saying and I you know
have bipolar issues it's not that
everyone loves that but there'll be some
people hope you know that whereas if you
say oh by the way I should tell you I'm
a schizophrenic hmm it has a different
it's the branding right it's it's people
talk about hum OCD but I'm really only
OCD in the kitchen I've got mental
health as if as if there's some kind of
calling card yeah
anyhow so yeah I could have done that
but I decided to put that off for
another day and it's just there's an
entire book just on that but yeah but I
decided I decided that the four I'd
thought about most and before I had been
Dean to most were yeah were gay women
specifically relations between sexes
race and trans and in a way the last one
of those was was the most interesting
for me because it's the one that we've
thinking about for the least amount of
time and therefore which I would argue
we have run farthest and worst without
having much questioning actually removed
from reality the most would you say yeah
well just things get was a wave by in
the general discourse which I don't
think I necessarily by and and I mean
the one that's come up in recent days
again sank thanks to Sam Smith has been
non-binary and I I just I don't think
there's any such thing and and I on that
occasion it's it's not for me to prove
that there isn't it's for people who say
they are non-binary to prove to me that
tell them or know just to tell me what
it is and they can't they don't they
just say shut up bigger and I'm not
interested in that mode of discourse so
regardless of whether you think that
argument does or doesn't have credence
it shouldn't be news I think everyone
should be able to agree like that was so
all over my Twitter that I just logged
out for the rest of the evening
yeah it is not a story yeah well the
news websites are partly responsible for
a lot of this there's a there's a
feeling I explained as you know in the
madness of crowds where I I say there's
some times when you feel the news isn't
the news it's about something else it's
some kind of reaction program I notice
isn't because I happen to be gay I could
probably say this where some have sexual
saying it might not sound so good but
there are days when I wonder how does it
feel like to read the news if you're
heterosexual because there's so much
about the gay thing I mean there was a
very very minor celebrity who have
married his boyfriend and it was
front-page news on the BBC website he's
a guy of such little consequence that
he's not even a well-known reality TV
star and he was like why are you telling
us about it other than to say gay
wedding gay wedding gay wedding mmm and
and that sort of stuff worries me
because I think well that's there's
stuff right that which I regard as being
what I call the the possible over
Corrections where to make up for
something that was wrong in the past
ie homophobia you over
correct and I think that's happening a
lot of the cases I write about in this
book the lot of the subjects I write
about in this book and I'm really
interested in it because then the
question is if you've over corrected how
would you know and how would you stop
and how did you get back to equal which
is pretty much all I'm interested oh
yeah it's you are right some of the
examples that use in the book like in
the business section of the New York
Times yeah Japanese the the Japanese is
a cultural approach to gay gay Pierre in
the bit in the way the main the for the
first two pages of business section in
your don't about a gay businessman in
Japan who came out and it wasn't the
problem because they're not a lot of
homophobic image about Japanese
workplace okay that is the definition I
know from being a journalist myself
there's a definition definition of a
non-story
something happened in another country
and nothing happened as a consequence
that the opposite of news
have you heard we've got a Canadian who
doesn't like cats
Oh anything happened no no cats were
fine about it and now everyone's go on
with the day yeah it's it's bizarre that
I don't really know I don't really know
sort of where to go with that you are
right though that the fact is
overcorrection
that were potentially moving towards a
situation where gay stories are being
shoehorned into the price one of the one
of the things that that instantly does
is it down regulates the virtue or the
integrity of any real achievements which
are made by people they're gay Russ aim
the same thing is calling everyone a
Nazi it's like if you have on a Nazi it
loses its power the same way is if if a
gay if a gay person in Japan being gay
is worthy of being in the news then what
happens when something really newsworthy
happens it's like oh whatever it's it's
like the thing of first woman or first X
of race in a particular role yeah
definitely times when it makes sense but
there are times when you know it's I say
say so the women chapters I there are
times in recent years when you wouldn't
have thought that for instance in
Britain we lived in a country with a
female head of state a female Prime
Minister female has a Supreme Court and
so on and just
you'd thought we lived in some Margaret
Atwood novel judging by the way in which
it's being written about and you sort
yeah it's not but we have women inside
and we know that like what are you doing
other than that some level in the median
I show how the tech companies have done
this to in some way sort of correcting
the public yes telling us or or tell or
saying it is another way of looking at
saying I dare you I dare you to mind
yeah sort of Greta Thornburg phenomenon
as well so I dare you go on
hmm yeah it was sighs a sixteen year-old
autistic kid go on it's certainly right
it's like in volleyball the this
whatever it's called that one before
they come in and they hit it it's the
little throw up in the air but it's like
look do you want to have a go at that
right have a go and it's okay we'll make
this even less newsworthy drill I got
that and if you do I'm immediately going
to be able to say you [ __ ] bigot not
yet I wrote a shite story and as it
happens the only people in the world who
jump up and hit that ball are all mates
of mine whatever like this striker or
whatever you having volley one there'll
be some volleyball people listening in a
tear in the Herrick so little we know
about volleyball I know absolutely
winging this limited my knowledge yeah
absolutes of domain of combatants and I
was gonna wait for this as well but I
wanted to ask this this question as well
since reading the book Piers Morgan
right get gets brought up a few times
throughout the book is it coincidental
or does he just happen to embroil
himself in these situations a lot what
the [ __ ] going on with Piers Morgan
that's the venting point I actually saw
Piers Morgan this morning his morning
show and he his wife wrote a very nice
column mentioning my book the other day
and I thought okay she's read it I
wonder if he has because yet the
reference is Tim are not that obliging
and unfortunately this morning I went
with a copy in the book and at the end
of the show just we finished recording
Pierce said is
one case per Douglas I said yeah go can
I have it that's it yeah no of course
and I thought well maybe I should have
taken that page out but never thee I
didn't know but he M yeah if he's
actually coincidence in a way because I
mean he's you whether one agrees or
disagrees or likes or dislikes or
whatever I mean he's definitely one of
those characters who throws himself into
things in his case we're just you know
Glee but it doesn't mean sometimes that
people like that are sometimes there at
interesting cultural turning-point
moments and I think to the to Kate times
he comes up in the book I don't anyone
viewing this to think this is like a
biography of Piers Morgan no it's I can
I can assure that he isn't but the two
times he comes up it's because yeah he's
sort of he's thrown himself right into
the middle of a culture war and
something happened as a consequence and
and if he's interesting there are
figures sort of slight lightning rods
for good and he'll who you notice yeah
crop up but I I'm one things I'm proud
of about this book is that I try to do
everything from looking at the
philosophy and deep ideas that cause
some things we're going through right up
to you know what happened on the view or
good morning Britain yesterday because
it's quite easy for people who love
books as I do to think books create the
world or you know massively influenced
or maybe they do have an influence but
so does television so does pop music so
does so does wraps that is twitter
twitter and and really that the
interesting challenge which I hope I've
managed to rise to the occasion of was
to try to encompass all of that say you
know this is the era we are in and this
is the madness we are going through and
to do that on everything from the level
of the deep deep ideas all the way
through to these television events for
instance which have a massive impact on
the culture you know if somebody is
destroyed live on air mmm-hmm for not
saying the thing that nobody said till
yesterday everyone learns everyone
you're right it's the BuzzFeed's 15
second clip Piers Morgan destroys
homophobic bigots live on air there was
a guy who was doing gay conversion
therapies one of the hospitals in the
book and one of the things I thought was
very interesting you have this quite
balanced view you went to go and see his
particular film and Piers Morgan had
annihilated this guy live on air yeah
but this particular individual wasn't
working with anyone who didn't come to
him wasn't saying that it was he wasn't
making a value judgment on gay or not
gay he was simply offering people a
service for that wanted to become
straight yes
you totally right this that was the
little ball in the air and Piers Morgan
just came in and hit the bigot button
yeah immediately that's right and I
actually I felt sorry for the guy in
question I mean I I caveat this a lot
and I say lawyer in a different era if
that he'd have had more power I wouldn't
have liked to have necessarily had him
in any kind of control this guy but if
look I mean if you live in a free and
liberal society then you know what's
good for the what it was sauce of the
goose is sauce for the gander or
whatever it is you can't just change one
set of demands of a society and then
just demand a new set and you've got to
express tolerance even to very you know
things you disagree with a lot and I say
there's a lot as long as it that that
group I don't like what they do but I
don't I don't think that I want to look
at their ideas I want to weigh it up and
I can compromise on conclusions but yes
I'm very suspicious of this thing where
people just are brought on air to be
shouted out and told their biggest and
then waved off into the distance why do
we need to be tolerant of other people's
views well I mean the main reasons are
the classical reasons for it that
certainly in the tradition of English
Liberty is is which is sort of the one
that became the idea in America as well
is that you need to hear other views in
fact you specifically need to hear the
views which are the minority views
because
first the basic the first reason is that
you might be wrong and if you are wrong
you want to have access to the
correction to your error and even if
you're not completely wrong you might be
wrong in part which I mean my own
experience in life is that that's
happened quite often I've had a
presumption and and quite often whether
that that whole process it's inevitable
we don't like to do it because it's it's
more work to correct your opinion when
you're wrong I mean as in fascinating
studies though the fascinating study at
Harvard the Cass Sunstein and others did
a few years ago it showed that you know
we might think that when somebody's
wrong it literally has the wrong view
that there's it's a fact they are wrong
about and they meet the correction to
the view we might think we tend to think
that the you would just say oh I see I
didn't dinner I was wrong but as anyone
who's had a boyfriend or a girlfriend
for a long time will know often it
doesn't work by that dig their heels in
even huh immediately say darling I guy
absolutely see your point
thank you yeah you know you and actually
the studies show that people double down
on their error but anyhow my point is is
that that's the first reason you might
be wrong and you should correct it if
you are actually wrong is for your own
good as well as a good society that you
don't go around in error but the second
reason actually the second broader
reason which is really insane is it even
if you're you're not in error and the
other person is being reminded of it
helps you keep your own knowledge of why
you're you're in the right right so it's
like a shot and like a knife sharpening
and while we're not allowed to use
metaphors anymore are we but but it's
the scrap that that's obviously
incitement to kill or something but but
anyhow but but but but it's it's a way
to keep our brains honed to to know that
we don't slip into dogma that's what
John Stuart Mill said about it that we
avoid slipping into dogma and up with a
reason why it's worth nots living in a
Dogma is just that you end up becoming
lazy and unable to defend things you
really need to defend and I think our
society is AI Phii say this and I quote
GHS
as well as Nicki Minaj in the epigraph
to say to say that our our era is I mean
is filled with dogmas and we pretend it
isn't but it really is I mean there's a
lot of dogmas in our society one of the
things that you bring up right at the
beginning is that you say that the grand
narratives that we used to identify with
the the root cause of this crowd
arrangements are thinking elapse of all
of our grand narrative yes what why is
that enabled this this broader situation
that we're seeing in front of us because
it's crosses all of that it's enabled
the gay the trans the the race
discussions do so sort of visceral so my
feeling is that we look there's
something incredibly deep has happened
underneath our societies which we're in
if not in denial about we don't face up
to which is we're living at a stage
where we might be among the first people
in human history to have absolutely no
explanation for what we're doing here
and no story to tell about what we
should do other than there are
narratives they're pretty weak ones and
accumulated as much money as you can and
enjoy yourself there's one yeah gain
some Twitter followers yeah it's not the
worst idea in human history but it's a
it's a fairly shallow one as I say I
mean this this paucity of ideas I say
it's it's obviously the consequence of
the collapse of religion which is pretty
much an irreversible issue now and the
collapse of organized religion the
collapse of all major political
ideologies in the 20th century other
than in the present structure which is a
you know called a liberal state of the
capitalist economy and I think that in
the last 10 years baiting in the wake of
the 2008 financial crash a lot of
confidence the self confidence was lost
in capitalism which is I think a
disaster in all sorts of ways because
it's you know as like Churchill famous
said up them said James you said about
democracy it's the worst system apart
from all of the others and and we've so
a really strange position where we've
really
run out of things to believe in and we
sort of pretend that we'll just find
your own meaning in the world and that's
one of the reasons why as I say I think
that it's very understandable that
people then get caught up in in new
ideologies of this and my view is that
the social justice movement
intersectionality all this stuff is a
version of it so it's a way to give life
meaning and the problem with it among
other things is that all of these things
equal what rights for women equal rights
for sexual minorities equal rights for
racial minorities and so on are very
good things and they are the products of
liberal rights but we've tried to
instead of being the products of them
it's like we've flipped the whole
barstool around and trying to sit on the
products of the right any it doesn't
support itself because as I as I show in
each chapter each of these not only are
each of these things gay relations mean
sexes race and trans not only are they
going against each other in very
interesting ways trans against women
trans against gay and so on but but they
each in themselves are more unstable
than we're willing to admit so for
instance we still don't know very much
about being gay we don't know quite what
causes it and there's been this study
that's just come out since my book came
out which sort of indicates what I say
which is it it's a bit more it's a bit
more complex than we pretend relations
between sexes and our attitudes as a
society towards women in particular a
very contradictory and we pretend
they're not so we pretend that women are
simultaneously exactly the same as men
and magically better on occasion and we
just decided to hold that idea and with
race we are very very unsure for good
reasons for good reasons because who
wants to open that up really well a lot
of people it turns out but I explain why
I think that's gonna be risky and then
you have the trans one and that's just
really really uncertain
really really not something we know
enough about or so not as much as we're
pretending and and so I just was saying
let's lean on all of these things a
little less let's not make everything
about these identity issues let's let's
try not to lean as much as we are on
them and try to get back to what I
thought was the aim which was equal not
better equal and focusing on the content
of people's character you make an
analogy between Martin Luther King and
his the content is someone's character
not the color of their skin which has
that if there was a bar stool analogy to
be used it's that now right that is all
about the color of someone's skin yeah
and then on top of that are they gay and
yeah yeah yeah are they did they used to
be a man and yeah how many more of these
can we layer on top that's how bar
stools being flipped right yeah and I I
think this is just all family dangerous
I found Lee dangerous well because first
of all just because somebody is of a
particular group does not mean they're
right or indeed particular it doesn't
always by any means if if ever mean they
have a particular right to be heard it's
true that you wouldn't want a
conversation between a hundred people
about women and none of them to be women
should be although the Catholic Church
has tried that no man but more than
hundred but but generally speaking we
recognize that that people do bring
confusion seven tirely sure what and
what the what the particular mix is it's
needed but nevertheless there isn't a
particular virtue you bring by being of
a characteristic there's a very
brilliant young American writer who
happens to be black called Coleman
Hughes who who mentioned this in an
essay a while ago I quote him in the
introduction that he said that when he
was a university quite very recent I
think maybe he still is in America some
of his contemporaries treated him as if
he had a special moral insight from
being black well see some black pee
obviously we'll have special moral
insights just like people of all sorts
of backgrounds and skin colors will but
but just being black in itself doesn't
doesn't bring that in the same way that
we all know I mean just because you're a
man or just because you're a woman does
not mean you have a magical virtue or
insight there will be things you notice
and there'll be things you can see and
but but that sort of it's that all
depends on the individual it's like if
you said I just think that women are so
clever or something you say well I mean
what do you mean if I say I think men
are all clever are we talking about it's
just there's individuals you point you
depending brilliant women I can appoint
you to plenty brilliant men am but
plenty brilliant black people as well as
plenty brilliant white people but why
would you be doing these categories and
what do you think they bring and I think
in each of them it's very strange is
almost like we sin in the course of my
lifetime I Chavan he just turned 40 but
in the course of my lifetime we've it's
always as if on these things we've gone
past equal and over corrected slightly
as if because men and particularly white
men have had you know certain advantages
I think there's a lot to dispute in that
interpretation but that for a bit will
be mean to them I will make white people
feel a bit of the racism that some of
them have expressed in the past to other
people in order to make up for the past
this car is a dream eken ISM to
compensate and if it's the same thing
with it's not enough that women are
equal we should also punish men a bit
and on each of these I think well
they're a set of questions aren't there
well how would you know when you've over
corrected who would announce it what
would the signs be and how would you get
back to equal and are you sure you could
you absolutely sure you would know how
to orient yourself it I mean they're
being by that point among others careers
and jobs and pensions of people who are
very
happy with the overcorrection mm-hmm
yeah there's a quote from your interview
with Candace Owens where one of you says
that after a while when I think she's
referring to black people and she says
after a while being treated as special
as black make being treated normal feel
like a being undervalued right I had a
um I had an Irish immigrant friend who
are best friends died some years ago who
you had a beautiful phrase on this he
used to say about integration he used to
say the moment when your integrated
really into a society is not when you
get anything special or anything x4
anymore and then when you're really
integrated is when you rise you just
have to put up with the same [ __ ] the
rest of us have to put up with I like
that but its indifference isn't it it's
the same thing as we do we do a
relationship series and we were talking
about how to get over someone and I was
saying that the ultimate ultimate
conclusion to a relationship and any
residual feelings for your ex isn't
hatred or resentment its indifference
it's seeing them in the street I'm
feeling nothing that you know that that
to me is completing it some people may
be able to actually continue on with
nice memories of their ex but that
indifference that again you're seen just
judged on the basis of your character so
I want to I want to jump onto the women
thing because the Nicki Nicki Minaj
quotes throughout just had me that I
absolutely loved that but before we did
that I only realized upon reading this
books I haven't looked that much into
LGBT recent history when did gay rights
get like amalgamated in with LGBT and
does that yeah it is there oh I don't
when you know you're not not exactly
like tip of the spear of like the gay
movement or whatever it doesn't know not
that you're the representative but I
wonder I wonder how gay people feel
about having to have their movement
adopted amongst this broader group
Pheebs it used to be gay rights and I
remember yeah you want I remember when
it was gay rights right I don't remember
when it became LGBT well it's the
history as
Dave Chappelle refers to alphabet people
in his recent show is he's actually he
has a very good summary of what I part
what I say in the gay chapter basically
the gays and the lesbians got together
and they didn't have much in common
other than the fight for lesbian gay bi
fact that none of them were interested
in each other yes I mean it's a really I
love the sort of presentation of the
LGBT community as if like the gays and
the lesbians never meet
they have nothing nothing to say to each
other in my opinion mics burns the
lesbians all find the gays ridiculous
because they think they're essentially
am sort of silly and obsessed with sex
and lots more and the gays think the
lesbians are kind of dowdy and boring
and that's the I'm not saying this in my
view oh no I love the I love the
interplay of the politics is great so
anyway but the point is is that no one
ever talks about this but basically the
elves and the Gees didn't get on at all
really ever and they're nothing calm and
the bees came along on the no what do
you quite believe the bees existed I
think there's still a lot of doubt about
that okay yeah well put it another way
most most men who say they're bisexual
women don't then women are women almost
never cool with that and the gays think
that's just somebody who hasn't made
their mind up yet and we with us right
or wrong I'm now gonna be accused of
biphobia all my other have many many
crimes but anyhow and then then then the
T's come along who have absolutely
nothing in common apart from also some
suspicion from wider society and the t's
morphs in the space of a few decades
from dressing up as something sama
clothing of the opposite sex to full-on
sex changes and this happens incredibly
fast now to this position where people
say there are people who are born
transsexual which is as I say in the
trans chapter it's all really
fascinating but it's by no means as
clear as that
but by the way I also say that the tea's
run against the elves and the Gees
overwhelming well now if a child is
diagnosed with gender dysphoria which is
a really troubling whole business this
80% of children diagnosed as having
so-called gender dysphoria will grow up
not to have it
ie they will grow out to be straight or
gay and a lot of gay men and women look
at that and they think that could have
happened to my younger self
you know that's or tomboyish lesbian
might have been told actually you're a
boy and we're gonna give you hormone
therapies and block your puberty and
then you can have an experiment you know
medically on you in a bit later and then
I mean that is really there's like a lot
of in totally right there's a lot of
tension pushing people towards the
extremes I brought this up with zubi
that I don't I don't remember the last
time I heard Tom boys like there's no
such thing as a butch girl anymore
or like a girl that likes to do sports
there's a future boy trapped inside of a
girl's body and one of the strange think
you see one of the strange think I mean
by LGBT that's a bloody minefield I'm as
I said that's just one great big
contradiction there but it's much worse
when you see what the tea dusts are the
women because women have spent decades
fighting not to be judged according to
male standards among other things and
then when trans comes along people who
were born men say they're women and
quite often do a lot of things and
approximate women in a way that is
highly offensive to women highly
offensive for instance I give an example
in the book of well what one second why
feminists in Britain described as you
know the assumption that a woman's
natural body shape is that of a sort of
Brazilian transsexual you know all all
big breasts and sort of horny and you
know and oh man a lot of women like
that's exactly the kind of sexual
objectification of by men of women that
we were trying to get away from yeah
and so anyhow that all of this the point
is all of this is just a bloody great
big mess it's much messier than everyone
pretends like oh all this interlocks and
if we can tackle trans rights we can
also address women's rights Cano they
might go like that like that and just
keep happening like that there was a pro
was an event the other day in the UK
there was a meeting of feminists British
feminists and they were bericht by trans
activists outside the police were
protecting the trans activists and these
people who were men until quite recently
a banging on the windows intimidating
the women inside and it's like trans
rights what what are the situation of
the men allowed to intimidate the women
open if the men say they're now women
when they wear heels that's when they
wear heels
yeah but see how likely when they're
allowed unless they take them off and
then start using them as oh yeah this is
really messy and everything in our day
says all of these things are linked and
it's really straightforward and I'm I'm
kind of pissing on that party in this
book mother yes there's a number of
parties getting pissed on in the book
here there is yeah I want to move on I
want to move on a Nicki Minaj just cuz
she fights she just first off she
fascinates me second she appears a
number of times in the book but you have
this beautiful this beautiful quote
which I think's hit on something that
I've seen and not known what it was
women can be as sexual as they like but
they cannot be sexualized and haven't
helped any man who responds yeah could
you just take us through that little the
Nicki Minaj video thing that happens
before because it's absolutely strikes
at the heart of what I felt as a you
know a young single man for quite a
while yeah I am I'm really interested in
these things in our age which are
basically impossible demands the most
obvious one is that I write about is the
insistence that there's a various
insistence that goes you have to
understand me and simultaneously says
you will never understand me yeah the
same person can do both of those yeah
all the time and we have that F
now there are other work things of just
impossible demands for instance ice at
one point I sight a ridiculous person
who complains on the BBC that they are
often ridiculed in public and that's not
nice but I point out if you're
ridiculous you will be ridiculed hey you
can't escape it other than by not being
ridiculous
and my favourite impossible demand is
the one that you just hit on there which
is the the demand that is currently just
very uncomfortably in the culture in
relation to the relations between the
sexes which is yeah women women are
allowed to be as sexual as they want as
sexy as they want but must not be
sexualized and this as I point out is
not possible now
does this mean that men can do whatever
they want obviously not obviously not
and you see this is one of the
conversations that's so hard to have
because somebody always leaps and goes
oh I suppose you're just a virgin blade
wait you know oh is it so you think
women should be raped no there are
gradations between total chastity and
rape you know that's how we're here
[Laughter]
otherwise we wouldn't have Skype we
wouldn't have you we will know Minnie
all the nice people watching it's just
just it but it's a sort of it's a sort
of dementing you know we don't allow
ourselves to have this conversation
Amaya point is none of this means that
men can do what they want but if a woman
is entering the sex game by being highly
sexualized that you know I'm cool man
that means I give them Nicki Minaj
example is because it's it's so overtly
sexual and and I particularly interested
in this video of anaconda I Bella where
the audible version of my book I read
myself and it means that I really have
to read the lyrics already already put
it into a video on YouTube and cut the
music over the top yeah yeah yeah do
whoever that is whoever that is ice
saluton you also to the to the people
who are listening obviously the link to
madness of crowds the book on Amazon
will be in there but I'm gonna put the
link to the audible version as well so
that you have to hear yeah yeah yeah
it's gonna be my party piece I can see
go on do Nicki do but no but the
fascinating thing about this this video
and I just I talked it over with a lot
of straight trends and I so what she
does in anaconda is among other things
all it's all completely sexual I mean
just totally sexual just how wiggling
her butt and her friends whipping her
their butts and they sometimes hit each
others butts and they sing about each
others butts and their own parts you get
the gist and and then in case none of
this is settled in she then has a scene
where she eats a banana sprays her
breasts with whipped cream and licks the
cream off with one of her fingers which
is also always impossible to interpret
and then there's this really interesting
last 90 seconds or so the video where
she crawls on all fours into a sort of
darkened room towards a very handsome
fit black guy in a chair and she just
does everything in front of him it's um
you know it's not justice it's not some
people say oh it's just like strip it's
like a lesk yeah it's a it's not she's
she's all over his body this is a thing
she's wrapping her legs around him she's
wiggling her bath his face she's it's a
total predatory thing and towards the
end of this interminable scene the guy
you see he's starting to you know and he
goes eventually and touches her slightly
on the side and she whips around and
smacks his hand away and walks out and
obviously the message of the video that
Nicki Minaj is giving is I can do all of
this but don't you dare think you can
control the game and this seems to me to
be a dementing demand a dementing claim
which is apart from the girls deeply arm
fed of men because
the whole problem of relations like that
is when does the game become about that
when does it but when do we enter the
sex business when are we in that
proximity and and the Nicki Minaj thing
is only if I get lead you all the way
there and give you permission all the
time all the way but if I'm just
enjoying myself in a skimpy outfit
wiggling my butt in your face etc cetera
don't you even think that you still
control the situation I control it all
the time either woman and I think that
is dementing and deeply unfair to men
and not possible it's not possible and
it's the sort of thing which our society
is really bad at thinking about because
we as I say we fall into these
incredibly basic things the woman always
must do X or the man must always do Y
and you see I think that one of the
things that's causing so much trouble in
our society is that simultaneously we
pretend that we know about things we
don't the trans one is the example ice
cave we just don't know very much but
simultaneously we pretend not to know
about things we all knew till yesterday
there is a massive amount of stored
knowledge we all have straight gay men
and women a massive amount of stored
knowledge we have about what is actually
going on in these situations and it's
it's complex but it's not as complex as
we're making it by putting these
impossible layers on top and and one of
those just add one other thing if I may
which is that one of the problems of
this of course is in recent years we've
been talking about etiquette of sex and
particular sex between the sexes through
the prism of Hollywood and celebrity and
it's just should be clear to us by now
this isn't the best prism to see these
things through it's I don't know it's
like trying to work out drinking
etiquette from geordie football team or
a Jordy or like it
or a Scotsman yeah I can say that I'm in
Newcastle summer that's a Geordie sir
right so but you know this has become a
real problem our societies because apart
for anything else I think young men
young heterosexual men are being told
things that are not possible to do and
sustained and you know and I I spoke
recently to a friend whose son had just
just left school I said I hadn't seen
Sam for a while friends with older than
me and I said oh how's the boy and he
said could I said what do you think
about girls he said there was nothing to
do with them and I said what I know and
I said what well he's not gay is he so
no no no it's okay
she's just they're more trouble than
they're worth it's it's just he thinks
her a nightmare and I've come across
that quite a lot actually because it is
it is being made harder than it needs to
be made I think the the relations
between the sexes has definitely got a
lot less exciting they did you remember
flirting remember one thing yeah same as
its it flirting's the same as tom boys
and emos remember emos where they've
gone anywhere emos I'm seeing an emo in
like I don't miss them I have to say you
get fair enough for too much eye shadow
but anyway you get me like you know all
these things like they feel like [ __ ]
nostalgia now I know flirting is an
amazing one because there's a load of
thing we just had this by the way in the
UK today about the ridiculous claims
that our Prime Minister once put his
hand on a woman's leg 20 years ago and
this is a headline this is the headline
on the day we're speaking you know
number one news item they're not like
there's much else to talk about in the
world is there but you know there's this
strange thing where I mean this the
point is this is so complicated because
again we keep having this stuff out on
that sort of level the former defense
minister Michael Fallon had to resign I
like being the defense mr. is a really
serious job it's not like agriculture
transport yeah no but I thought
transport relations are my gotta get the
farm
[Laughter]
no no their transport people I don't
mind losing but they're never there but
it's not like transport so your Defense
Minister you've got part of the control
of the nuclear capability you could
destroy Paris if you wanted you it's a
serious job embroil he's embroiled in
touching a woman's leg or something and
and and and and somebody as it happens
who are who I know a journalist in the
UK had told the story some time before
this he touched her knee or something
and she'd said again not all women can
do this or want to do this it's not to
say this is always good but this this
woman you know said if you keep your
hand on my knee I'll sock you in the
bloody face or something he took his
hand off pretty fast
that was it that was it and then you
know 15 or 20 years later the story came
out again he had to resign I mean this
is so in a way it's a sort of a British
sex scandal there's no sex
it's like Liberal Democrat sex scandal
they're always that like that there's
always like a fat man asked a woman for
coffee and she said no and that was it
and even if any asked to resign and that
actually happened it actually happened
anyhow the point is is that these are
people look at this and they say what
exactly are the rules and the answer is
we're making them up as we go along
which is not uncommon but we're making
up rules that are completely
contradictory and I give the example in
the book of like what are you to make
growing up of the fact that you are
simultaneously told that women must
always be believed and the most popular
book for women in recent years the Fifty
Shades stories where women have rape
fantasies but growing up is hard anyway
and these levels of not being able to
discuss things mean that people just see
these totally contradictory messages in
the culture and I don't blame them for
being utterly bemused
and you know what the solution is the
solutions that of your friend's son
which is just to exit to just be like no
it is I can't do any sense making I
either don't have the desire or the
capacity
or the [ __ ] sanity to spend my time
thinking trying to work out where the
rubber meets the road to this issue so
general it is simpler for me to simply
not engage right
recently I got asked to do a job for a
particular company as a brand ambassador
as a part of this I went on a training
course with them and the training course
I run nightclubs in New Castle the
training course was about sexual
discrimination and sexual predation in
nightclubs now as a nightclub operator
that's something that is the calling
cards that you do not want you do not
want that that story in your in your
venue and the group that were that were
giving the presentation throughout the
whole course there was this odd
undercurrent where it was supposed to be
equal between what men were doing and
what women were doing it was supposed to
be that every example for instance would
you throw this woman out of your venue
if she did X Y Zed and one of them was
like Lifta top up and expose her breasts
to a group of men and the equivalent for
the man was like take his pants down and
expose his penis to a group of women and
in the in the bureaucratic elements of
it it was even in the rhetoric and
narrative based elements it was
exclusively women being the subject of
some sort of predation by men and I down
the road from this I actually went
through the course then sent an email to
my agent and said I'm really sorry I
just can't I can't get on board with
this I think they're doing is great but
I'm concerned I'm concerned about the
delivery and I think that it may make me
out to be a target which I don't think
is quite right I don't think they've
quite got the course correct yeah email
them and say sorry but one of the things
that I brought up while I was having
this big course and it was run by there
was I was the only man in the room and I
think of the five or six women there was
only maybe one that was straight so
there was a number of different layers
of
if going on wow that's a high ratio yes
sure and that one of the things that got
brought up there was about what women
wear on nights out right and about how
they dress and I was trying to say I was
trying to be as empathetic as I could
and my empathy scribbling Olivia's
empathetic as I could I don't say one
look like if I had a daughter I would
tell her to dress carefully that would
be the terminology - I would you
absolutely absolutely
just dress calf yeah immediately there
was a quick sort of head snap to the
side where it's like well why well right
if I need to explain why then I get
pushed down this hill and at the bigger
yeah yeah ya know the bottom of his
death you I mean here's one way I try to
uh try to get to where we need to get to
at least in having a reasonable
conversation about these matters in
white society is is there such a thing
as a predatory female so I know I
learned on that course that there's no
such thing as statutory rape as a woman
in English common law right which I
never knew there's sexual molestation or
whatever the one down from that is which
would be the equivalent of a man putting
anything which isn't is penis into a
woman but there is no no such thing but
go outgo of a stage from that to just
normal interaction as it were a non non
physical interaction can women prey on
men absolutely right this is stored
knowledge that we've pretended we don't
have everybody knows it everybody and
it's unbelievably dangerous to talk
about this I give example in the book of
the Indiana Jones films one the Indiana
Jones films there's a famous scene where
the whole class has sort of a very
attractive young women all looking moon
earlier Harrison Ford and in his
teaching and there are
see hot you know archaeology guy which
is of course completely familiar in real
life anyhow he he's giving the class and
one of the women on the girls I mean
they are girls really in the cloth has
written love you on her eyelids and it
and she blinks at him so he can see this
and yeah I find this fascinating because
this again you can sometimes sometimes
it comes up as a meme online still but
everybody knew this time it was so
familiar as a type that was a woman or
even the young woman making a really
vert play for the male it's so familiar
there was in family movies and what
about the spinster with the toy boy you
know and we sort of pretend that these
types don't exist we sort of denied
ourselves access to archetypes that we
pretended don't exist
it's unlearning really important
learning yes well
because in in these things we're in the
realm of for a lot of this you know
because within the law as I saying
earlier there's just that we're in the
realm of manners and the manners manners
are things that you your best trying to
acquire as you go along from other
people and learning from your elders and
I think and the elders at the moment are
saying we don't know what we know we're
not passing it on don't touch don't lots
to figure it out for yourself yeah and
and by the way some of them are men
that's the no isn't it that's that be he
a home be home by one yeah but it's just
you know they say it's complex it's
complex but it's not as complex as we're
making it what do we do to move forward
them several things the first thing is
we have to realize what's going on and
like just get out of it we have to get
out of this we have to get out of this
zero-sum game particularly the zero-sum
game whereby in order for we think for
women to do better so men have to do
worse or for gay people to thrive
straight people have to do worse or for
black people to
white people have to us you've got to
get out of this this is just so
unhealthy
it's it's waste of individual life and
it's a terrible opportunity cost for
society because none of it is fixable is
my view you know are things you can do
worse than other things you can do
better but we're never gonna fix it it
there's never going to be the lovely
interlocking Nirvana that means that we
all move to some perfect state it's just
not the case so what should we be doing
and this is the really this is this is
the thing and I think that a lot of
clever people and particularly people
who have certain advantages in their
lives
I helped through this and they know how
to get through this era I give very
exact various examples of this there's
sort of cuttlefish phenomenon among
others but my point is is that there are
people who've worked it out and I'd
quite like their knowledge that among
other things a lot of this is [ __ ]
to be more widely understood because we
need to get out of the other side of
this in larger numbers now my view is
that this is this is because it's partly
just something for people to do so it's
a lifestyle choice of its own and a
hobby and a religion among other things
it's worth thinking what what what
should we be doing then if we're not
doing this but let me put it this way I
mean imagine if we actually sold the
identity politics thing which I say is
not gonna happen and what would it look
like it would look like us saying it's
great I've worked out where I am in the
hierarchy this morning and I'm allowed
to speak between 11:30 and 11:30 - and
you do that for some decades then you
die now I'm not up for that and I trust
you aren't either
no no what could we be doing well I
think we should be hugely ambitious and
I don't have all the answers by any
means but I know that we should be much
more ambitious than that in what we're
gonna do
I we have the 21st century ahead of us
we have better luck than anyone in human
history anyone not just anyone
alive today but anyone alive ever so why
would we be wasting our time playing
identity quick-fix politics I would
submit that we should try to get
ourselves off this in order to dream
bigger dreams to do really meaningful
things to not work out what we shouldn't
be doing and what we're not allowing
ourselves to do and what we don't think
is in our lane but to break out of that
you know the the the something a Jordan
Peterson and I and others have discussed
a few times in the past has been this
strange view of life in this era as if
as if the ideal life is to be harmless
like harmless from cradle to grave not
cause harm at least I didn't emit any
co2 and I never never upset anyone and I
never spoke when I shouldn't have spoken
and so on I just think we've got to
break out of that and say no no the aim
of this generation is not just didn't
he's not just to be harmless as our
highest aspiration its to be
extraordinary to be great to be
inventive to be intelligent to be loving
to be caring to be great in all of our
personal relationships if we can and
recognize it will fail a great deal but
do as well as we can and then in the
rest of our lives be extraordinary and
and and and great and do things that
people will talk about for generations
afterwards and look out with admiration
you know we don't look at the great
buildings of the past that have stayed
standing and and look at them with
anything but or and I can't see that in
this generation if our ambition is to
look at our navel long enough to believe
we've understood ourselves totally and
then die I see nobody standing looking
at a statue of that and think if anyone
could do that in marble and thinking
those are the guys I think that's a
2,000
really nails and yeah yeah I get it I I
agree I agree yeah I think that when you
think about how much energy goes into
these issues these nan issues
and some of the first off when you think
about how much dilution of real issues
is done by the non issues and then
secondly when you think about how much
talent and cognitive power that could be
spent on real genuine lasting epoch
world-changing stuff and and and just
and just just just another wonderful
thing on that which is you know this
whole thing of hold yourself back stay
in your lane timidity is exactly the
opposite it's exactly the opposite of
what successful lives look like caused
by yeah it's not I wonder how I can make
sure I don't veer out of my lane but how
can I burst out of my lane and into the
world how come how can I do something
unbelievably meaningful and important to
me in my life and that will benefit
other people too there's there's an
aspiration but it's entirely in
contradiction to what we are told so
break out of the era
I'd say Douglas today has been
absolutely fantastic thank you so much
for coming on the madness of crowds
everybody who is listening or watching
if you're on YouTube the link will be in
the show notes below where can people
hustle you if they need to find you
online Douglas I'm on Twitter that
Douglas came Ari and I do have Facebook
and things like that you are not Douglas
Murray 3 on Instagram as I found out
earlier on today those all guy there's a
professional footballer at I think
Washington State we've got bluetick so
there's there's an ice hockey player who
shares my name in Sweden
ok because I used to have a colleague
who used to check it when people were
saying things about me and I said I
don't really like to know about that
but she she says how old what's he done
now cuz it be like Marie smashes
opponent and then grinds him onto the
ice and go obviously my my name is Chris
Williamson so the number of anti
cementing accusations I've had but I did
I did live Island about four years ago
so I went to in love Island and I
I often post like oh my my anti-semitic
alter egos at it again and one of our
friends
one of my friends commented on that
below saying I wonder when you get in
the press whether he says off for [ __ ]
sake my love Island alter egos done it
again so yeah but Douglas thank you so
much for your time wandering ascetic
it's made I've made a lot of sense to me
I hope it makes a lot of sense to
everyone else as well I hope they enjoy
yeah I thank you at the time it's been
great thank you
[Music]
you